[Musique]
oui ça vaille 36 ans je suis adjoint
administratif à la région réunion au
département je siège à la commission
permanente et ma délégation se porte sur
le développement des structures
d'accueil de la petite enfance
[Musique]
alors je suis conseillère départementale
sur le canton numéro un donc qui
regroupe piton saint-leu les avirons et
l'étang salé je tiens à coeur ce canton
car je suis né et j'ai toujours vécu à
l'etang-salé fait ma scolarité aux
avirons
alors un sujet qui me tient à coeur pour
le département c'est effectivement de
lutter contre l'insalubrité des
logements pouvoir aider et on va dire
aussi accompagner les personnes âgées et
les personnes porteuses handicap je
souhaiterais également travaillé sur
tout ce qu'il dit la petite enfance
pouvoir faire évoluer on va dire
faciliter les démarches administratives
pour pouvoir avoir des agréments par
exemple je souhaiterais et veillez
surtout sur l'égalité des chances faire
que le sport et la culture soient
accessibles à tous de jeunes car cela
permet l'épanouissement personnel il
leur donnait aussi les moyens
nécessaires pour les amener sur le
chemin de la réussite
favoriser la qualité de vie de la
population
il est nécessaire aujourd'hui de mettre
tous les acteurs économiques à tous les
collectivités main dans la main ensemble
pour pouvoir voir sur le terrain
réellement ce qui se passe ils mettent
beaucoup plus de proximité avec une
population afin de mieux répondre à
leurs besoins je veux vraiment faire le
lien entre la vie réelle du citoyen et
les solutions à construire avec les
moyens du département je veux que chaque
réunionnais retrouve sa dignité et que
l'humain soit au coeur de nos projets
futurs